You can tell a lot about a country
from its passport.
Color is the first giveaway.
Nations tend to pick colors
that reflect their national character.
New Zealand decorates
its famous rugby team,
its airline, and its passports
in the nation's favorite color, black.
Many Islamic countries
have green passports
because of the importance of
the color in the Muslim faith.
But as well as a statement
of national identity,
color can demonstrate
international cooperation.
The British passport was
originally a regal navy blue.
But after Britain joined
the European Union in 1973,
it switched to burgundy red in
line with other EU countries.
The common color was supposed to make
European passports instantly recognizable.
But since colors can't be patented,
nothing stops other with the same idea.
A number of countries
that aspire to join the EU
have changed their
passports to burgundy too.
Meanwhile, Britain has
decided to leave the club.
Its government has announced
that the UK passports
will revert back to
navy blue after Brexit.
If you have a passport from
Singapore or South Korea,
you're in position of
one of the most powerful
travel documents on earth.
Passport power is measured
by the number of countries
the holder can access visa-free.
Currently sharing first
place in the power rankings,
Singaporean and South Korean passports
provide visa-free access
to 162 countries each.
British passport holders
share fourth place
in the power ranking
with six other nations,
each accessing 159 countries visa-free.
Americans rank fifth with access to 158.
Somalia, Syria, Pakistan, and Iraq
are among the world's
least powerful passports.
Afghanistan is the lowest-ranking of all,
with visa-free access
to just 26 countries.
Having to get a visa is a hassle.
First, there is the never-ending form.
Then there are lengthy
appointments and expensive fees.
Some visas also require
travelers to pre-book flights
to prove that they intend to return home.
But there are unexpected upsides
to some of the world's weaker passports.
Middle-ranking Namibia is one
of just a handful of countries
whose citizens can enter Angola visa-free.
India is one of only three countries
whose citizens have
visa-free access into Bhutan.
A low-ranking passport
limits your choices,
but not your sense of adventure.